[Music]
in 2009 a satellite circled earth
methodically scanning and sorting the
wavelengths reflecting off the planet's
surface researchers were looking for the
spectral signature of carbon dioxide
when they noticed something baffling an
unexpected wavelength of unknown origin
they tried looking at earth with only
this wavelength and saw the planet
covered in a red hue of varying
intensity this couldn't have been
reflected sunlight because it was a
wavelength that never escaped the sun's
outer atmosphere and it didn't
correspond with densely populated areas
suggesting it wasn't human-made either
in fact it was emanating from places
with lots of plants the amazon basin
northern evergreen forest and croplands
of the midwestern u.s were all ablaze
so
what was going on
plants and other organisms use light to
grow by way of photosynthesis but that's
just one of three ways that light
entering a photosynthetic organism is
used and this is the key to solving the
mystery to understand the others we need
to begin with photosynthesis during this
process sunlight hits structures within
a plant cells called chloroplasts which
are packed with chlorophyll pigments
when chlorophyll molecules absorb light
some of their electrons become excited
they go through a series of reactions
which transform light energy into
chemical energy this powers the
conversion of carbon dioxide and water
into glucose the simple sugar plants
need to grow and of course this reaction
generates an important by-product
photosynthesis which is constantly being
carried out by plants algae and bacteria
produces all of earth's oxygen
but plants regularly absorb more light
than they're able to consume for
instance over winter the frozen leaves
of evergreen trees can't photosynthesize
at their usual rate but they're still
exposed to a lot of sunlight if not
dealt with the excess light can damage
their photosynthetic machinery
so the second way plants use light is by
transforming it into heat and
dissipating it out of their leaves the
third way plants interact with incoming
light is by radiating it back out at a
different wavelength
producing what's called chlorophyll
fluorescence
during photosynthesis the chlorophyll's
excited electrons move through that
series of chemical reactions
but as some of the excited electrons
fall back to their ground states they
emit energy as light
overall about one percent of the light
absorbed is re-emitted as wavelengths at
the red end of the spectrum
it's such a small amount that you can't
see it with the naked eye
but plants the world over fluorescing as
they photosynthesize
and this is what's caused the earth's
baffling red glow as observed by
satellite it was an accidental discovery
but a huge breakthrough tracking
chlorophyll fluorescence from space
allows us to watch the planet breathe in
real time and monitor the health of
ecosystems worldwide
previously researchers used levels of
greenness as the main estimate for plant
health because plants generally change
colors or lose foliage when they're
stressed higher levels of green
typically indicate healthier plants
but this measure can be unreliable
in contrast chlorophyll fluorescence is
a direct measure of photosynthetic
activity it can help us infer how much
oxygen is being released and how much
carbon is being absorbed in a given
system
drops in chlorophyll fluorescence may
also occur before visible signs of plant
stress making it a timely measure
scientists have already used chlorophyll
fluorescence to monitor harmful
phytoplankton blooms and track the
effects of drought in the amazon and
great plains going forward we'll be
investigating photosynthesis from space
and gauging how best to support our
silent friends who already do so much
for us
besides helping us keep track of our
ecosystems we rely on satellites to keep
our daily lives up and running so what
would happen if they all just
disappeared find out how the world would
react and the odds of this actually
happening with this video